wilderness areas are incredibly
important because we need to have at
least a few areas that we can go and
feel like we're still connected somehow
to nature the wonderful thing is it's
land that we can all share and we can
all use and not one person owns it and
so you can come out here and feel like
you kind of own it for the day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Vermillion cliffs National Monument is
on the Arizona Utah border it
encompasses 300,000 acres for public use
you can go for days exploring in the
backcountry and finding all kinds of new
discoveries my first job with PLM was
back in 2000 I was stationed at a remote
site out in the middle of all of this
and I fell in love with it and didn't
want to leave I feel like my job is to
help educate the public to protect
places like this Vermilion Cliffs is
most iconic ly known for the wave it is
gorgeous it is an undulating slick Rock
sandstone but the wave is not the only
feature in this beautiful country there
are so many other things to explore here
willing to make the effort
[Music]
why pocket requires incredible
commitment to get here skills to
navigate some pretty tough roads and
you're dealing with a lot of mother
nature's worst elements getting here is
a big reward I'm free out here
a lot of us kind of scratch our heads
because we don't understand how a
landscape like this can be formed but
all of these things are shaped by Mother
Nature over about a hundred 90 million
years and so it's pretty incredible and
it's fascinating to marvel at how long
it's taken to create this great
sculpture the beauty of this place you
can't compare it to anything else
[Music]
[Music]